今日は外れ社長です何かな pdr さんとリベルタスがなんか増加で氷に氷今ここに
いつ50キロ不安ですよね
氷につようですねかけるとなんか化学反応をってなんか暑く夏よろしいですよ
あ危ないで真似しないでねあいつらは何かこう
てになっこうちょっとだけ校
お塩を塗ってさ氷をやっ
ちょっと吹いてさ
あないよきっ見学には5千キロであるわけでナンパなんか僕は全身で出来る人みたいな
ことふりをされたんで舌診でやりましょう
火傷したら
危ないねかっこいいよ
はいどうも農法はいというわけで早速ね
購入続スイカで結局やしたんですけどもバンバン
降臨のフィロを作ろうと思います
西してねあっ
おっ
ええええええ
ああああああ
tan
dee
ん
よしよし詰めた
ざ氷の風呂はできたんですけど冷たいんね
国家もお塩ぶっかけますただよくそうね使用札こわってんだよ
薄めれば何とかなるって書いてあるためためだと思いますなぜ押し合い入れるといった
けどなんかねえ
うわぁいろいろでやばいん
たしています
南極みたいはい距離で完成したんですけど
だけはけっています
こっち行きマッチますもんでチャンスって瑠璃子
あ
ああああああ
tar
voodoo
わっはっは
千葉っていうとなってん
ダメだダメだこれはためだ何ん
なんか体が全然的に凍ったんだよ
ダメだダメだこれダメだダメだダメだ
痛い痛い痛い
k 犠牲ていくつ選んだけどされる
ten
この部ズーム実は氷なんですよ
ほれ
ここらへんも全部実は凍ってますだかよくわかんないですけど
体が全身的に凍って
やめておきましょう